and then what happened was a major event
happened that was
that changed the whole course of human
history that was correct betsy it is a
human genome project
right it was a giant british and an
american efficient
and um effort it was a race who will
complete first it was a racist not
whether they have
to take drugs but whether they can
actually produce them
and it was all the human genome project
was sequenced
right so what happened was this ended up
to be the biggest breakthrough in the
field of informatics
and that has caused the birth of many
many many many disciplines
right and so we are now in
a whole data tsunami right big data this
is where it actually started but it did
end there we are still doing a lot of
data right and that's why we are all in
a luxury state that you can actually do
projects you can actually discover
things yourself it may seem odd
but each one of you can actually find
something new because there's so much
data that we still need a lot of people
to actually look at the stack
so now at the conclusion of the human
genome product what happened
it actually created a whole new field of
science and medicine
called the genomics right and now
it is completely a whole new field of
genomics
virtual genomics then what happened was
the human genome was sequenced
and then that it didn't end there then
people started going crazy and started
sequencing more and more genomes
right they started sequencing and at the
end of the human genome
we had 3.2 billion base pairs of the
human genome right
and people started sequencing more and
more genomes of drosophila
rat and chicken and mouse and all of
those things
so been used when you think that we are
the most
important uh people on on this planet
right and we are all trying to solve
diseases we are all trying to cure
diseases
when once the human genome when they
declared that it was
sequenced why do you think it is
important to
actually sequence the genomes of rats
and mouths and chicken why do we care
why do you think we have to sequence
other genomes why did people do that
any ideas any guesses
yes comparison right that's right so you
want to compare
because you know what we cannot do and
to study evolution
that is perfect and to study evolution
but you want to compare comparative
genomics right
for example if i want to find a cure for
a disease even for cova lab test correct
so even if for example kovid 19 right we
are trying to create
like what 20 different groups in the
world are creating vaccines
trying to do vaccines you cannot do all
of that
in humans right and to do all the
testing we have to first use
what are called the model organisms we
want to test that before we actually
test it in the human
right so that's why we had mouse rats
and chickens and everything else was
sequenced so that we can do comparative
genomics
of what is different between humans and
them for various research purposes
right to create that create a disease
model and so now but what happened is
because we have sequenced
so many genomes now and so many
everything else and we have so many
proteomes right now
it also comes with a lot of different
challenges right the challenges that we
are actually facing today
is the number of sequences is exploding
we have 106 billion nucleotides
we have more than 6 million data from
environmental sequences alone this
we are not even i'm not even going to
talk about this unless one of you is
interested i can talk about this later
and then we have lots of uh in
a in uniprot knowledge base which we're
going to be talking about and you will
have lots of hands-on experience with
unicrock
and then from the sequences we have
domains we have
three-dimensional structures we have
protein families
we have clusters of orthologist groups
and all of those things this is
just we're just talking about proteins
in dna i'm not even talking about
other data sources like medical
electronic health records medical
records and any of those things
that's going to be beyond the scope for
this lecture so i'm not even going to
talk about those things right
and now how are we going to deal with
all of this data explosion